[Musique]
peuvent ils pas qu'au vu d'un andré
c'est le moment de l'année au village
québécois d'antan de drummondville
s'illumine
oui à drummondville parce que on en vit
vraiment d'éliminer ce noël et le jour
de l'an et qu'on était un petit peu
triste pour la plupart alors on a créé
ce spectacle lumineux 25 et 1000
ampoules sur place que l'on pourra voir
ces photos qui sont envoyées à ses
majestueuses elle c'est 100% l'extérieur
à cause des raisons sanitaires que l'on
connaît on nous plonge dans un village
québécois du 19e siècle donc vision 1830
à 1870 et on y apprend d'ailleurs sur
place qu'on festoyer autrefois davantage
au jour de l'an qu'à noël son recul
vraiment l'époque du pelage noir c'était
vraiment au roi la messe de minuit
on mange ensemble aurait dit le ministre
comme à chaque fois mais elle avait une
touche plus particulièrement du sco jour
de l'asse le cours donné les cadeaux
d'ailleurs on donnait les et rhein au
jour de la alors c'est vraiment là que
les festivités prenaient tout leur sens
on se promenait dans les rues on allait
souhaiter la bonne année à nos voisins
alors on faisait du porte-à-porte
pendant cette journée là pour souhaiter
la bonne année à nos voisins et demain
vont en profiter pour ouvrir un petit
coup ici et là ce qui pesé qu'à la fin
de la journée lens connaît la maison et
l'un chrétien bombe ce soulagement aussi
pour toute l'équipe
on ne put enfin rouvrir les portes du
village parce qu'habituellement on peut
entrer dans les maisons cette fois-ci
impossible évidemment on a ouvert
seulement 14 jours cette année ou du
côté de drummondville alors on était
bien content de rouvrir cette fois ci
est de miser sur les activités tout de
même qui nous rappellent le temps des
fêtes pour le carde enfin le sien pur
bonheur de voir ça alors on se promène
dans les rues on voit toutes sortes de
belles choses on se laisse envahir par
cette magie est évidemment mais ça
nécessite également un arrêt à notre
pays
nous on fait nos banques sur place etc
des beignes vraiment gigantesque et
baigne dedans tu as et qu'on peut
choisir c'est vraiment incontournable
cominois et cette année mais puisque
c'est uniquement extérieur là on a taxé
aux maisons art comme on a des tours de
carriole qui nous sont offerts
gratuitement
alors pour se rendre sur place il faut
vraiment avoir réservé sa place parce
qu'évidemment le nombre de personnes le
nombre de villageois est limité cette
année en raison de la pandémie
merci andré o voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit